sometimes do you not feel like sometimes
some women are behaving the way they are
because men are not actually being
traditional men anymore oh my God yeah
yeah preach I think I think that's part
of it not in a I'm not saying in a
negative way that oh like you're not a
man but I feel like you you know how you
said on you said on the live show that
you know you guys we should be thankful
to you people because you guys have
given us the opportunities like we have
right but do you feel like you guys have
even managed us let's say what you're
saying is true but do you feel like you
guys have managed us as the men you're
meant to be
let me ask them one question who creates
those men that you're talking about
facts women right so that's your answer
there because the thing is right you're
saying about oh men being traditional
men
but but here's the thing though right if
you tomorrow if every woman in the west
was like you know what let's take sex
for example you know what I'm not having
sex with you unless we're in a committed
relationship every man will start or
would start acting correctly no I agree
with you so in regards to okay what is
the minimum standard that a man has to
bring in order to get a woman
as women you all set the rules and
that's why I said in the live show so I
did say that men conform to the
standards that female sit exactly so if
your standards are low you're just
playing into our biological imperative
we just want to have sex and keep it
moving if you don't control how you um
demand sex then men don't have to do
that so the the problem with Society now
is that women want this oh I'm a mother
woman I can do what I like I can sleep
with as many men as a man can sleep with
women what does that do you end up
pregnant the man doesn't want to stay
around the man leaves for whatever
reason then you're raising a single
parent you're raising a child by
yourself you put your kid at every
statistical disadvantage by raising them
by himself plus simply women can't raise
men so now you raise that man that you
talk about that you don't like but then
it's men's fault but then you have the
choice of who to let in but then it's
still a man's fault I think is there's
nothing wrong with making those
decisions like that like we live in a
free Society right part of being a
modern woman is being able to choose
what roads you want to go down yeah but
then if you Cho if you go down the
modern the modern path there are for a
traditional man yeah I was going to say
how do you expect to have a traditional
man if you're trying to break every rule
of a traditional woman exactly yeah
look I'll always hear it like there's a
called why men love [ __ ] and like
girls read it yeah
girls girls girls read it
and so like they'll sleep around or get
in a certain position or whatever and
then they'll say oh if you just raise
your standards but you can't like sell a
used Honda Civic at BMW prices the men
aren't stupid
yeah but this but I that you saw a [ __ ]
you're coming to me like I want a high
value man it's like who the [ __ ] you
think you are yeah but I also think that
there are some men there are there are
some men that are spoiling the market
because it's giving this with these
women that are half like are naked look
good yeah you're giving them this
entitlement because you're giving them
the attention you're giving them the
money you're paying for their bills
you're paying for this so the next guy
they meet they're gonna want that
standard as well and they think they're
entitled to it because what's been given
to them for however many times that's
your own individual lack of
self-awareness because and a problem
with a lot of women now is that you
forget that men or dogs so you might
have a guy who's like a 10 who sleeps
with a girl that's like a three and now
you think you're a 10 because you slept
for 10. no I'm talking about the girls
r10
I'm talking about the girls that you may
not want to marry but you'd class that
as a test I'll be honest the girls the
girls that are 10 are getting married
they're getting married 100 they're
getting married okay tens in terms of uh
the overall package yeah oh you're
talking about it that's what I'm saying
so okay are you talking about the
Instagram girl the girls the girls that
are test but not wifey they'll find a
simp yeah that's true but what yeah
because because I do think that men say
oh yeah you know you're gonna get banged
but you're not gonna get married not
every modern woman that wants to get
married so you banging them and giving
them what they want is actually all
they're after so that's what I'm saying
in terms of just repeating that cycle I
don't think that's completely correct
because the majority of women still want
to get married and have kids
okay yeah because they'll say like I
don't need a man and then but I want a
man and so I'll say okay what type of
guy with you would you want and a lot of
times they'll start with saying oh I
don't want to get married and then when
they describe the guy that they want I
say okay so if that guy was interested
in marrying you would you want to get
married and they say yes and so it's
like the problem is the guys they want
just don't want to marry them because I
thought part of the month-and-day woman
was that they're more courage or even
the more they don't really want to have
children and get married it was that
they want to have children get married
but they don't want it to hinder
anything from a statistical standpoint
yeah women by and large still want the
traditional family unit yeah yeah so I
literally searched this stuff up like
it's something like 60 60 70 of women
still want to get married okay but
basically you want to get married on
your own terms yeah I think I think what
I think what's become more of the the
normative culture for a lot of modern
women is that they use the years up to
the age of 30 to pursue their career
heavily and then they get to 30 and they
realize you know and it's a real thing
you know biological clock and go oh well
if I'm gonna have kids I kind of need to
start planning for it now yeah and then
and what happens is they start
prioritizing having a family and stuff
which is fair enough but then they start
asking for the different kind of man so
what they were asking for before was the
attractive guy that all the other girls
wants maybe the rappers whatever the hot
guy or this it's all good looking all
this right and then they get to you know
30 30s or whatever and they're like yo
that guy was fun but he wasn't gonna be
commitment away I just want a nice guy
do the same thing
[Music]
can you see
and as they get older they then start um
making better choices in the women that
they're sleeping with and who they would
like to have as a wife
but there's a difference though for men
right the game is different from men
because if a guy is progressing in
himself in his life in his career in his
steps right him getting older right he
can he has the option to choose the girl
that he was just going to fool around
with or to choose the more if he's
looking for like a family traditional
sense the point is he also has that
optionality simply meant increase of
value over time whilst women decrease in
value over time whoa
yeah that's great I agree with that yeah
can I just ask can a modern day woman
turn back to into a traditional woman
she can be a traditional she can be a
traditional woman in practice but in
terms of in
I think there are some I think there are
some things that
a traditional room moves a certain way
in when she's young that's going to
benefit her when she's older a
traditional woman is pure as a virgin so
but by that definition no you can't
become a traditional woman I think you'd
be traditional in practice like as many
of you know I was just banned on Tick
Tock and we are demonetized on a daily
basis on this platform if you want to
help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible